as what so who podcast man welcome to
the worst or full podcast we have a
guest Rick a CGI right here it's Guetta
he ever that many times that like for a
mad fool tried right here all the way
from DC New York New York the East Coast
but the real Toria from the 909 nine
five one eight five one seven one four
before 909 another nine five one hello
we all say with seven oh four seven one
four yeah back in the day share it with
Orange County for real that goes that
was probably on the probably went for
about that Ontario was nine o night
always yeah that cuz I was still kind of
Amarillo le it whatever good like want
arrow improv where they that Ontario
they know what hard way and go towards
the two fifteen that no go east
everything on the side of the ten before
somebody no the alto back down didn't
they get rid of 909 and everybody had
tattoos word on the street there was a
show called The OC and there was a there
was like episode episode we had a
backyard party in the Orange County
somewhere I don't know looking on that
girl whatever yeah and then some thugs
came back there and they pulled out a
gun
oh my car little Omaha did I oh my god
these guys are from the 909 City Council
and I don't know if if the City Council
or the Board of Supervisors held a
meeting where they're like there's a bad
connotation with 909 we've got a
separated and make it to nine five one
I agreed well vote da boom changed it
seven one four split into five six no
seven one oh no I have no idea
that's a good question Tiger boys we
used to be civil for nine oh no before
ninety knowing that 909 was seven one
for Riverside was a city roof sudden
excited
no more night well I don't know what who
pulls the strings but I think it's with
population and phone numbers as well
because everybody said gerrymandering
yeah that's another [ __ ] Power
movement listen I'm proud to say I'm
still 2 1 3 2 3 yeah my neighborhood
started it was 3 to 3 so that was a new
number that read 2 or 3 yeah I met
somebody in Santa Monica
yeah yeah when I moved here in the New
Jersey no from Eagle Rock area Eagle
Rock now Washington Eagle Rock Highland
Park you hung on a Eagle Rock Marlboro
oh yeah when the movie theaters was that
Filipinos the Filipinos in to take over
have you seen it now I know they have a
bit bball the Express little Manila no
no Holly B know the supermarket you were
surprised at speech for you right there
yeah yeah
that have been there for around four
Sizzlers right there though right ever
since they lost the movie theater down
hill that mall just turn off the lights
they make it a haunted house watch that
underwear in the restroom at Macy's oh
my god somebody changing a baby and I
mean the same thing oh wait I've thrown
my good underwear right oh you're going
to with a bag you rip it in there you're
done that rigged my underwear right away
right away because nothing happened oh
yeah I had to unfortunately you're gonna
gig on a gig bro when you get there you
realize you're something happen man
either your bag didn't make it or you
forgot to pack underwear or you had
nothing man and you just I like this
show it's gonna be one night but it'll
be in two nights
yeah and you have nothing target and
target always go through for me oh yeah
oh Jesus oh we're through my clothes and
I fall you're about scared about the one
you put on your on your leg when you sit
down you want that aspirin that one I
bought another one have like a smaller
size always that the mobility know their
stance belts they're actually they come
in they click on heroes what do they do
no well what I do is I put them between
my my legs that way my legs don't
stretch out all that I don't asleep
because I had an experience with a hairy
ass dude private about for your boy
shorts they were disgusting dude he's
like he touched me I can feel like
cells exfoliated on my skin [ __ ] it dude
I had to get an outbreak costume for the
rest of you be like Evel Knievel fan bro
welcome to being a girl every dude I
said Oh Pig I'm in first class bro and
he was too easy though even were even
worse he was too lean over bro he was
loud enough very viciously but I left
Felipa bar the belt cuz he did have a
belt one time for a show and I don't
know where is that one who gives a [ __ ]
dogs but I guess he found it but that's
the one I would eat raw I think Greg
gave me those those bats bro those one
dad the dad pants yes all the bells took
her nature those dad belt oh and then
but that pass and as wait a minute man I
think Greg he also gave me underwear and
I think he didn't go by it gave me his
no he did who buys one pair a box yeah I
see thirty bucks
oh we put him down he was expensing it
though would you use somebody else's
underwear or would you go there I know
the person law dude if you the dirty
Morano probably not commando bro your
commandos fine line you need the extra
filter but you see Joe Diaz hairy ass I
don't have much of my body here I just
have this book in my ass and push the
little baby here I saw his uber driver
get out of his car to help somebody with
a you know a bag at Burbank Airport and
his pants were just down past his cheeks
like I saw his ass crack
that's gonna take at least one star off
your rating right there you see Joey
Dewey rage hi Rage Against the Machine
on Josh Anna Myers yeah I saw that that
was pretty it was pretty dope man every
time enjoyed the other work just turn
around yeah how's it go Josh that I want
to be a rock star huh I guess so
apparently that's where he's coming from
with
what oh I want to be a musician until
I'm on stage trying to sing and your
dream changes really weird different
than the rest of my fight I mean how I
know it changes bro because oh I know
you guys seen the Joker but seen a movie
two times yeah hi I'm Antonio and and
what you already know this bad boy as a
comedian man you see him going over his
jokes with himself
yeah and then he was going over his joke
everything was looking good but when he
went up on stage he couldn't really
perform the joke the way he did in his
house and that's real yeah story know
that that's real like never give a
spoiler right now I knew the whole time
that that girl wasn't really hanging
with them cuz like just no one would
hang with you after that set a pretty
good time
nobody has ever made love to me that
after a sad bro especially G will go to
somebody's how they make our there me
but you would have to standing ovation I
know I know
forty month yeah and he Bob right like
really badly if you bomb would you ask
somebody another comedian in that lineup
right then and there that night hey why
don't you book me back at three years I
would not be talking I have a comedians
a crime you got to leave the scene I
have a comedian come up because you
don't reciprocate what you just did
come on at least wait two days yeah what
the word bombing you witness and they
they tell I'll come to you after and
talk to you as a weirdo like you saw the
guy rape somebody I won't be a fan stay
away it's a worse oh I don't know it has
to be like a summers ringer show it has
to have been so no no no the guy show
Louie the words that you brought ten
people to watch yeah yeah yeah down and
now and those were the ones I I've seen
those be and only for the then you good
said see you nice Joe is T Kate always
talk about him when you're I will see
him two weeks ago at the federal and he
came and he gave me a spot like ten
years ago
okay and I haven't seen him in ten years
mhm and I went up to see hey what's up
because hey you wants to show dick you
know I don't know I got no I did you
shows ten years ago I want to bomb again
Carter yeah
last name Cardinal Madison Madison
they're the wig the guy with the wig the
wig the other ticket I don't have a wig
yeah well that's that's well it's
assumed yeah totally yeah yeah
like from a bald guy I'm ballsy right so
that's a wig I'll call it out just call
it away with that well somebody has big
hair you could tell right away oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yes age eyebrows lines
that shouldn't be there's like the
funniest shadow there's like a 78 year
old dude oh the young black chick you go
those football commentators that end up
saving their head recently and big
they're free now yeah the moment is over
they've graduated yeah Steve Harvey got
rid of hair he was happy yeah absolutely
these two areas here in a box yeah go
back to the airport to pick up Steve's
hair forget it dog huh you would need
about I did that I would want to back up
right right there ready put one in each
bag and you know I mean like one on me
somehow I guess I know how my hips are
fighting I'm gonna leave it on bro
people do have cancer up there bro it's
a pity laughs I'm a little bad Bobcat
going up there live in a farm bro with
two parents with [ __ ] strands bro
I won't even the two no front hair bro
I got one over my I was watching but now
these shows the way the station it's
called a wheat channel I think one is we
in one's TLC yeah but the way they
promote their neck I'll show that cover
night but the way they promote another
show that's coming up a new show they
show commercial with half of the other
showing you know something like that and
like networks all crafty huh wait a
minute my other show the disaster but
this [ __ ] is crazy we got [ __ ] Aaron
Carter and mom talking [ __ ] oh yeah
Corey Feldman and his mom and brother
Corey Feldman comes in brought a little
time I haven't seen these guys had Lost
Boys by the way right because they're
talking [ __ ] discussing all I am I've
been over 100 and I hate to brag about
my career but I have been in over 100
movies have you seen me do Michael
Jackson have you seen me do or vice
versa laughing at you Cory
I'm not laughing at you Cory did a
performance performance on TV on a
morning TV right
a little bat rolling away a little bad
it's weird yeah and and and then he
caught on social media I guess he wasn't
on social media at that point but he did
it so he could kind of talk to all the
fans right we're watching him that
morning they all [ __ ] all over him and
these comments it was like you know what
social media yeah you learned pretty
quick Korey fold monroe's crime I was
thinking about that today like the first
time I put a video up on YouTube and I'm
like this is great it was like from the
Craig Ferguson show like everyone's
gonna love this
and then just people start [ __ ] on
and I'm like woah I don't like this at
all I don't like the Internet and my
family's from Ecuador I'd do this joke
about being from Ecuador small country
and then they titled it comedy time they
titled it why Rick thinks Ecuador
they're leaving comments before they
even watch the other comments like oh
well you must be saying some [ __ ] just
chill my plug in this show I'm gonna
come on Netflix but and so Devon IVA
came out yet it's called gente fight
it's a play on we're done gentrified
right so they put the release you know
flip press bar says go know where the
co-star is Felipe and for the characters
right and everybody from Boyle Heights
where I grew up in right people who call
themselves Latino X they said they
stayed up all can't believe this [ __ ]
show than a sellout making our
neighborhood look bad and you know
people comment about Philippe is gonna
be in it yeah what's his agenda I read
the whole article they haven't seen one
second of the show they have no idea
what
nobody Chucky [ __ ] they're like yeah I'm
really disappointed to see Felipe
supporting something like this because
they feel like it's exploiting the
neighborhood Oh Glenn all these
businesses got business and everything
when their movie was being shot like all
these people got work and like I know
well now as you say people need to be
upset about something every day and that
was your day the split between oh who
are your fans who don't you know they
might support that idea of fighting
gentrification which is a fine fight you
know but some of this some of their
ideas are a little far out there and
they're a little triggered by every
single thing remember that video that
girl that girl walking in New York and
getting cat call yeah so I did a video
just like that walking in LA but she was
fighting back yeah I did this whole
thing and I got millions of hits but you
look at the comments like 2,000 3,000
comments and all of a sudden realized
they were all just bailing out quick
there's a fake fake and at the end I put
it it's a comedy don't curse you serious
yeah you know none of them make it to
the end like you said yeah look the
beginning fake fake and I look deeper
and their kids
yeah they're kids dude they're like 8 9
10 year olds that won't be quick judges
and move from one video to the next and
more than that they get in it it's
worldwide yeah man if I met Ron you had
to put a fake Twitter to get on people
by hairlines earlier Stephen Miller you
see that one
and it on one time and then didn't have
the pin you understand his email he made
the wall was a message again so what you
start comedy at ten years ago la
downtown just walked in an open mic was
open mic it was one at a printer shop it
was like a sixth and spring near the
down-and-out you know the down and out
of the bar yeah and then it's just a
printer shop that was doing open mics I
walked up did one set and then but
fifteen years before that I tried it at
the at the open mic at the Comedy Store
and suck what we're here we're talking
25 years ago
yeah 25 years ago I tried it that balls
was there to Igor no you know who is
hosting was Larry Melrose Larry annoying
I don't know the guy who was on Howard
Stern yeah put me down do when I walked
up that guy goes what the [ __ ] just
having to hit that with a clipboard hit
him with his own signed by somebody you
didn't even know as a piece I was young
I was young and I said you know what I
go I knees right very scarring mr.
bellos green and then I came back 10
years ago I said come on let's do it
Wilbur said did you wrote did you grow
up around Rollie no no no I didn't but
we grew up around the same people and we
knew a lot of my dad owned a club in a
silver lake called cachet on a Glendale
Boulevard across from the Red Lion that
German bad its Rockaway Records right
now oh yeah yeah and so my dad owned a
club there cash a Paul Rodriguez my
Rockaway Records no it is rock moved in
my dad lost the business in 91 and then
Rockaway open okay cool so but it was it
was a lot of good 80s my dad had like
celeea crews over
Tito Puentes and and all these famous
Latino artists asuka Fernando Valenzuela
at him gave him a Miller Lite myself my
dad was a pilot but I don't a service
and I was just an awesome moment how are
you there oh yeah it was fun there's a
lot of a lot of fame it's weird the
Rockaway Records stayed in business I
know yeah yeah yeah started selling
space let's put a Leo to have our room
but we need to have a records before it
was you going out together hi bro man
grabbed like at least 35 records LP I
never heard of that so stop playing on
one by one with [ __ ] hipsters behind
me waiting join my back bro just to do
that
awesome you sections walk yeah and then
there was one section with one room it
was all Beatle memorabilia and it was
like real hardcore [ __ ] we're talking
like blankets posters little 45s first
pitch they used in LA they threw out of
the Coliseum and then now they had other
stuff there I bought I bought a poster
there Tommy be worth money but now let
me tell you that was a collector
anything you have that you think is
worth money if unless it's a painting
anywhere [ __ ] really though there are
only a few of the only Batman comic book
should be worried about Batman number 14
that's where [ __ ] I'm the Joker
appeared I know that because I lost boys
but still yeah comic books baseball gets
harder John yeah [ __ ] does a
documentary about Facebook dude that is
so badass baseball cards a guy who was
making money Moreau making money in the
80s with baseball cards killing it has
more stores and his kid then he left his
kid left his family and this kid saves
these baseball cards and he shows all
these 80s like videos of him and I said
oh now he's an adult he's got all these
baseball cuz I'm gonna go cash in he
left him at the mark the night of the
Bar Mitzvah well good nothing but he
wanted he went to a
place this guy that used to own up a
debt yeah who do you have you have that
what the cacique oh yeah see that hole I
owe they're all Canseco about baseball
trader show and his sister ran over the
cards yes yes you saw it go inside to go
I'll give you 20 bucks yes this guy's
like plan yeah I'm gonna sell my dad I'm
gonna throw this out ours if you don't
come get it you go to college no I'm
just gonna sell my dad story I'll be
good he reconnects with his data yes the
dad bailed on Miz but right yeah give
out credit don't add a new the video her
die out yes yeah when he will die out
yeah he saw yeah you found out that he
[ __ ] every chick II hired yeah you
realize what a big lie you livin in huh
yeah they were talking about with the
talking about the value dropping once
nobody cares nobody cares but it's the
same thing with like diamonds and stuff
you know it's not inherently worth
anything it's not like the events you're
talking about the availability of yeah
De Beers bought a diamond got the
diamond mine the first diamond mines and
they had them they just cornered the
market on that because nobody else
they've held all them back and storage
like they held a stock back so they were
rare all of a sudden the rarest diamonds
and then you know they're pretty and
sparkly of course but then they became a
value because they made it rare then
they started saying how much guy should
pay for their but it's really worth
nothing it's not like other precious
minerals and things about value with the
posters if there's not too many the
original baseball cards a Honus Wagner
there it really isn't too many oh yeah
what they did with upper deck room
the ken griffey was going to be the new
car happy words but these [ __ ]
printed [ __ ] warehouses full of cards
and devalued that [ __ ] yeah that
happened and they show that in the
documentary Schools Board those [ __ ]
diamonds are just worth more just
holding it supply and demand they're
controlling the big little motion I
gotta admit in there but he was like
deal with the dad situation that you
know that one kid you know as soon as
his dad dies apples gonna die three days
later dog yeah man so tight his dad oh
yeah yeah his dad left he sold
everything all the businesses to other
car collectors like better than you the
future you yeah you did your dad he sold
me the business before he left for a for
like 20 G's yeah that's so true but you
know one cool thing about the dad
none of those old fools they're not
nobody bad trash talk to Daddy said he
was always an honorable person a moral
person your dad gave me where he started
me in this yeah hey I know you and
that's what I would give little kid
couldn't believe it cause I [ __ ] left
me you guys you guys heard of Armando
Munson it'll narrow finger yes okay so
my dad wrote a song for this famous
singer I'm in Mexico I'm going to school
now Vanetta Wow Wow growing a university
down there can build on and all the
Mexicans down there like a good English
ghetto that's what they call a peachy
get English get that cuz I played
football down there and I would speak
English everywhere oh boy a soccer
all-american football down there yeah
yeah it's
our month there was a singing contest
and our month Amundson it was like
giving autographs to people I have
people all around him he's giving
autographs in these Mexicans are like
and I go hey who's over there he goes I
have to stay skipper you don't know you
know you don't know and I saw those are
month of months and I said I don't hit
ya so how much did you guys bet me if I
walked over there and I you know held
that guy and I pushed everybody excusing
company so I say you're my side arrow
people pass and Lucas get them they go
oh my buddy's like those jaws just
dropping and they all had to pay me 20
bucks that's awesome is how you dive got
in the business with music and booking
bands and you know he got in just by
playing and he got the club and then he
started bringing the artists to LA from
all around the world and so that's what
he got known for and that was like 84 84
85 he started and then he lost it 91 and
then he just did he write a song they
just have this song ready and wanted
somebody to sing it I was a kid I'd wake
up every morning to him playing the
piano there and then my my friends were
black and they would go hey your dad's
playing Como stucco most are like yeah
you know and my dad would play you know
Spanish romantic music you knows what
his stuff was that's that's a Raimondo
Montanaro each sounds he's got a
romantic oh yeah he sounds like like a
chipmunk yeah yeah he's a very romantic
saying it's a yes sir
my dad would I would wake up to this
every morning like tomorrow introduce
again
Mickey Rooney or something you guys
heard of you-know-whats Annette yeah
that something's not here Nelson ed
would perform there and he'd love coke
man he's dead now I don't care he's
little person here you know who loves
who what Ted through a little Nelson ed
reference at well coyotes and sing a
song joy Diaz oh really
he's Cuban right yeah
oh no Nelson is Brazilian really yeah
but he's he was well-known in the in the
Latin community but but he would do a
lot of coke yeah I know they do and seen
a little man like that like talk to you
like talk [ __ ] to you he said good don't
oh yeah do you call him Nelson the voice
the giant boys yeah the giant boys and
he would come out like and they would
put a like extra stage for him and he'd
be like a little spotlight chasing him
around you know like and then he just go
howl in guy and he would say macho man
knows that was his joke he would like
for sports subdirector he's like three
and then one time I was taking pictures
and he got mad at me any chick
and he was yelling at me I was like I'll
kick your ass
17:16 give a little Massimo ass yeah
he's a my brother Adrian
that's his Godfather Wow yeah my brother
here he was his God my brother Nick
you're all gabardine ski yeah I got
married in my backyard in 87 86 years I
let it kick it doctor lady yeah baby
yeah yeah yeah come on you know it's a
cord yeah Charlie the truth Dominican
right yeah I don't remember the
Dominican you know like comedian uh
little vignette oh yeah the choreograph
furfle for a teacher :
oh she was yeah or trying to eat one of
the ladies I just remember my brother
used to put his like underwear up his
butt crack like a thong and he'd go et
chuckling yeah the partner now so what
well you were there Oh your dad that
Club
yeah well the name of the club you've
got yeah do I put his shirt Brad's at
that Club with a rod and a 70 my dad
went to it yo yeah yeah dude my dad will
go out bro lame I found out that my
mother to go out there oh yes some
Mexican singers yes all a lot of them as
well yeah like those love song people
right yeah yeah yeah but yeah Paul
Rodriguez - and I thought I would I
don't buy this question of you did I
have a lot of comedian show up just
bought just Paul really nobody yet Oh
Spanish city of Khurana showed up and he
had a girl he got drunk in the girl I
was talking to her next you know I go to
a hotel with this girl and my dad's
telling said my son [ __ ] your date yes
that's the only one I could remember
okay comedian when this one was there so
no nice perform on your death Club what
were these dead you have a house or
hotel okay sell your clues slept in my
house okay and and I took my buddy Tony
he knows this Tony Camarena
we're friends we've been friends since
82 probably I took him up the stairs to
say hey you want to see celeea Cruz
she's older aquadude I and she was
sleeping on this bed our guest bed and
she was like and she was snoring loud
and you look at her face like the light
and it was celje Cruz and he said that
is I said okay what a beautiful snow I
gotta win this party you know what I was
such an idiot
I'll be honest with you guys I was such
an idiot I thought it was cool American
kid and he and my dad will be there cool
a big deal with ya you're not here that
you know the rapper who like DMC Paul
just told me at the birthday party come
on focus
yeah yeah a lot of these idiots a party
to [ __ ] a pillow drumroll faster Rico
suave was family friends okay really
Gerardo yeah Gerardo he wasn't [ __ ]
enough colors and I saw Gerardo I think
I saw her pop lock for the first time
who's a dancer and those were so Willie
Barcena inspiration for the bandana
[Laughter]
Richard Grieco and Richard Grieco jr.
Richard Grieco Instagram page today his
head looks like it well you homie so-so
Tarara I heard Rico suave it before it
came out why'd you lose your mind when
it would begin that that was huge
I was you but it's kind of funny right
at first living to be the law when he
showed it to me I was like you know what
is it dude no for real I said dude I had
to lie because I was like I was 18 and
we were doing a nightclub together at
the caches give me a bub are you just
totally natural
very Christian it seemed like cleaner so
yeah and he was never here throughout
the whole thing and he's really not
always about the business delay he was
looking for the next thing huh yeah and
Enrique Iglesias he helped him he helped
them Rica yeah and he was in a movie
with court McGowan oh yes yes named
after you that funny other big show that
we my dad and I went to word at the
million dollar at that time oh yes I'd
had to go with my croissant deep
philosophy Polina yeah I had to go with
my grandmother to those my dad would say
you have to take your grab how'd you die
get into the business
it was just he'd be playing music and
then he bought the restaurant well the
restaurant yeah the nightclub the night
before that oh no oh it was up yeah and
there used to be a guy with the top hat
hanging outside it was really
sophisticated you know rich for rich
people and then all of a sudden he got
it and it got a little bit more just let
not just Latino but we're giving Latino
audiences I mean shows and so we're
gonna get Latino audience I would go to
school and kids would say hey my parents
want to bring you over for dinner and I
go oh really why cuz Jose Jose is coming
to town you know and I would be there
they hate can you tell you Danny
oh yeah I'll talk to my dad so parents
would be Jose Jose just passed away oh
yeah was there really though I heard
that Jose was saying was always fighting
with his wife yeah I don't know that
that's [ __ ] but but Nelson Ned did shoot
his wife in the face she did yeah no she
survived oh okay the bullet you know the
be shooter and then he died recently
yeah I mean very coherent some if you
like if you have enough money to do coke
you live forever huh no
confirms Willie Nelson smoke no what are
you telling I don't think they do it
anymore
I think coke is root like kind of like
you can have a that's right I'm sweaty
right now
they also your heart can just go yeah
you can have a heart attack yeah you
never died you know aspirational comedy
while you're down the club oh yeah
close god yeah yeah this is Commodores
come on let me bring up on second oh my
dad one won't make his bed my dad wanted
me to be a singer and my I have five
years old over here you make me sing in
front of the family and friends and I
would see Donny Osmond go away little
girl older brother go hit his muddy cool
um yeah
like just because I would watch my dad
coach singers and so I would get it but
there's something there's some notes you
you just you normally can't hit it's
impossible to hit like one right like
Mariah Carey notes once your finger
starts going like this yeah so you stay
within your bars yeah anybody could sing
you know it's all in the breathing did
you check out any stand-up shows in the
80s in LA I was wondering that would be
like you know um I believe I did you
know where my dad would take me la caza
fool I don't know why was that he was so
into the transvestites singing like
Diana Mikasa floret lucky he was in
Hollywood so much somewhere but it
doesn't exist anymore I think but it was
when transvestites with a lot of Latino
action also uh Grand Central Market they
had drag show there that that went on
for many years and I what I'm saying the
ladies were saying was the guy was
dressed up like chicks and sing and the
girl just saw like dudes and
I'm in the Mexico City I see nobody
nobody consider a gay growing up alright
it was it was a circus show because they
actually like them yeah could we can
afford to see the rules yeah yeah Bobby
all those dudes when my brother got
married his bachelor party
my dad took them there when you gather
were performing there you don't ever
have bands like remember when I was
living in LA when if we first came to LA
they should be a local band though
living and living next to it but they
were like across the street we could
here practice they were Carlos Diablos
okay yeah you heard that bad
no they played Chicago they were local
they were like a condor okay ya know my
dad had a cached salsa like 12 piece ban
and that was his and they they would
rehearse every day for Thursday Friday
Saturday the weekend to be the [ __ ] and
people would go there and and it was
live and and actually the John Candy
movie where there were security guards
we're all like remember that movie yes
huh going berserk
know what I don't know the name of a
dress armed and dangerous that one they
filmed a scene there Eugene Levin there
with it yeah with him and Eugene with
the two girls and they're sitting then
there's music going on that's the
restaurant
that's the Kachin and some way the Tom's
man the two cops come up to ya movies
funny I got about that movie I love that
yeah party met with me when they [ __ ]
out with John Candy and
they get fired from that warehouse Chico
they reported an actual robbery yeah it
was a security go from in a place and
they sent him to go work at his [ __ ]
auto shop place with [ __ ] it yeah it was
like there's a nitrous it's like
petroleum yeah and there was a -
security gonna be working there seven
days straight they're like all itchy
yeah Wow like Ward's growing a little
face I like the other part where they
set up to a warehouse well as soon as
like the shift starts the little 3mm
pictures and it just changed the whole
another one where they have to sit in
that tunnel in downtown LA and make sure
no one breaks down and then they get all
smog poisoning and [ __ ] or is that
something else I'm thinking about
there's probably a police academy if you
can't remember a certain plot and
must've been police academy these guys
were guarding trash like yeah I was a
trash and walking over it and talked
this job sucks right yeah and they would
see another guy he would be excited
hey this is a gold mine there's a comb I
found like Oh movies used to be funded
right they take it too seriously now
they're just take it to have a message
yeah yeah we need more comedy though I
think we need more of that slaps like
crazy laughs yeah or make photo what's
going on now like back then like little
kid nobody had jobs but they made funny
one was about no one having a job yeah
like easy money you should like mr. mom
yeah mr. ho yeah all that [ __ ] Japanese
company showing up but even yeah we
oughta Lunardi that's like it's like you
lose your job that's when the fun starts
my favorite movie favorite part dirty
work is when he's in jail because he's
getting out he said you guys should be a
sheikh he'll inventive over yeah what's
up [ __ ] you start doing stand-up comedy
in Spanish now or yeah I have a probably
about fifty three times about two years
ago
attempted first one and I didn't want to
focus like Richard via like going to
Mexico and stuff I just don't say bad
words on this okay so you don't want to
Mexico yeah I'm gonna beep that I didn't
want to go that deep so I I just
everybody say hey you you do Spanish
right and I said yeah okay you know
let's go let's do it and so it's just
been fun it's been fun it's kind of
keeping me on my toes and and I went to
school in Mexico two years so you know
that's the good thing i noticed that i
lo hace ii way you know sometimes i can
i can relate with my these people
because if i go or you give us a little
game I so get it and then they go bigger
fight he's freaky too fast and he's one
of those guys who thinks Mexico people
[ __ ] because that's how South America is
it's a big racist you know it's worse
than know about your Tina well you got
you got put corner so you ceviche right
yes yes we put corn nuts
isn't it good yes but I saw a video of I
think that guy from Bizarre Foods
he went to Ecuador okay and they were
making a ceviche bro and I've seen it
like other product i've never seen that
well that guy could have took the fish
you know really thin yeah my god we
chopped it up carpaccio [ __ ] yeah
we're like over like like a prosciutto
with a fish and put on a big ten and
then I'm getting another fish and they
had a low shrimp that's many and then he
added like this hot sauce like a
habanero or something and then the lemon
he just mixed it all up and then end of
the coordinates see I wanna if I was not
beating up I want to taste that but I
like the coordinates that we have here
like the corners I don't have they have
these ugly shell coordinates that are
like have that popcorn plastic around it
I told you that guy I worked with in New
York there is more soupy right yes yes
but it's more like a shrimp cocktail but
with all that without all that ketchup
and more orange and lemon and more pink
onions and mango mango with it huh I
think my dad makes it and it's like they
keep it a secret they keep it a secret a
secret yeah you guys got something
really cool by ecuador's there's this
part called the iguana park right in
Pico Rivera but there's only Guana part
actually like with iguanas caja and when
I was a kid my grandfather would take me
there'd be like 1 or 2 and you look at
the quietly you wouldn't see too many
and then all of a sudden today look up
iguana Park in Ecuador and do there's
like 20 that come down because you know
they know they feed them Cheetos then
they're like yeah so you're not supposed
to eat them it's against I look to the
restaurant next door in MacArthur Park
we're right next to where the LPO he too
used to be a right and there they have a
it's called Mama's International tamales
and have um our section as non vegan but
they have also section as vegan but next
door they ever not show authentic
sourdough a restaurant and they serve
fried meat Wanda was right the beach
yeah yeah yeah whatever
I've never tasted right next door
there's a reptile store
they wanted a little truth a little old
all the guys with big lizards in the
shows coming up this week yes I do
oh man I am very lazy right now don't
even remember what I have but yeah I
think I got something
my Instagram I'll be in Fresno Covington
covering Tversky Fresno's 594 alone
right he's totally cool yeah yeah yeah
eight land then Laughlin then Laughlin
after that nice and then yeah just your
headline in the Fresno yeah yeah no no
no III do it well along with Allen
Cunningham we're co-headline or yeah
it's like three of us
Troy do like 2025 hold on the show oh
yeah
Andre Cummington and Cunningham Allen
Cunningham it's hard to say say that ten
times no but I am headlines the what's
up call in in Laughlin what's that one
in Laughlin yeah and that's fun that's
fun it's on the ritalin oxygen team then
I gotta go to Honda on the casino which
is the Monday show it's just a part of
the package in the drive for hours
Monday no that's no that's entertainment
max Barry but I always say I always very
real but I always say yes to the Honda
because they're the first ones who
headlined me like years ago and they
said you need to do 45 minutes and I was
like five only does has the budget
change in four days you were doing a gig
in rich Chris called China Lake no no no
yes go the China Lake in Moreno Valley
dog
yeah yeah just some hell gigs bros for
that dude yeah but always be do we pay
you she still sends you a chance they
prolly you done brawler yeah what's up
you what's up Molina
no I did it with Bobby to know
oh sure okay okay yeah man there's a guy
call we'll stop you right now is papi
chulo the same as son dubious no two
different guy was food this week in San
Antonio being San Antonio October 26 at
the Tobin Center second show added
looking for that man sound Co now man I
mean if you're gonna want to look for me
I'll be walking on a River Center just
like the Joker at night
San Diego November 2nd at the Humphries
by the bay West Jordan Utah November 8
and 9 wise guys comedy club Modesto
California November 4 15 at the gallows
eater the Gallo Center let your Mexican
got your Center Bakersfield California
November 16 the Fox theatres of right
next in the Napa California November
22nd Uptown Theater Seattle Washington
November 23rd at the Neptune theatre
that's a bad at Little Theatre I
remember I smoked into the green room
and I just opened a window they were
nice to me there Spokane Washington
being Cosby or Crosby November 24 did we
meet a lady the new Bing Crosby she had
the story of how I was that name - Bing
Crosby theater and how he used to live
there and what's wrong oh yeah also map
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania November 29
through December first talking about you
should fly in on things gave me for
radio let me tell you anybody I'll fly
you to get there early but I know there
will be no press the answer things
giving for a Mexican guy in Pittsburgh
Gordo Townsend there's some job you got
it right there's some time that you
evaluate you don't gotta worry about it
man because I saw the people gonna show
regardless because try the day off
yeah then he should I guess it'll be a
little harder to fit the people there
and then fit the other man second sure
how many green goes have you overlock
you man that's awesome whatever and then
he gets up he saw Gertrude and then she
[ __ ] gives him the phone take a photo
I don't know how to work this all right
she's all happy look at this photo and
funny people yeah a lot of people broke
for Last Comic Standing
that's awesome so when you got to wrote
a lot with the comedian's I know I used
to go on a road with I never really went
on the road brought me to chose whatever
so that we did were in what a battle we
went nowhere bro I'm sorry I'm seriously
we wouldn't it will never went nowhere
it literally only took one and driving
them back home back in the four bites to
see that fool go up some stairs I got
spider bro Willie Barcena
get loaded dog but he's going up his
stairs false imperative the car
there's no handrail
like houses on yeah you take a break
like in the past then it sucks every
time he doesn't have a key
he's just started banging at the wall
waking up everybody who wants to wrestle
yeah he would clear lobby furniture in
hotels jiu-jitsu no way oh yeah
yes you and him in underwear no hotel
room with that singlet so what happened
bro yeah he liked wrestling
oh yeah he loves wrestling we should I
worked for him for five years I went on
the road wouldn't be right yeah it was
it was it that was too much it's too
much
oh my hair too much yeah lost all my
hair I used to be like Phillippe it when
I started comedy
I lost two credit card bill hello use my
house no look here's a goodie Willy
disclaimer great guy love the guy's been
a good friend he's got a big a whole
stamp on his forehead he even knows it
right he acts like a dick but he's
helped a lot of a lot of people he's
helped me as well
but he eat [ __ ] me over you know and
and but we have that balance you want to
build a guy with no hair so he there's a
big story about him leaving me in
Arizona shut up no [ __ ] way so he
left me in Arizona bulletin yeah hahaha
his credit card in El Segundo and he
took he took like the funny thing about
it was I was having I was having I was
selling a lot of merch and he left me
you know he let me cuz yeah she goes so
much tell him which has bongos what I
was selling t-shirts we should have said
tienes kata they got a lawyer you have
Weiner on your face that's a joke I do
and then so I was selling them and they
were selling really good and I even gave
Lily one to say hey man I don't know if
that was more like more like throwing
alcohol in the cut boot yeah
somebody look at a hundred dollar bill
and then taking it back but but his
story is you haven't enough fun of fish
Paul but his story was that that I left
that I I would I was I was a jerk and I
said I left him at a bar I abandoned him
you know at a bar but after the shows
what would happen he was like you get
drunk and you say if you listen to me
you'd be good and then in like a fans
telling me how much they loved the show
and I go that story so famous now yeah
awesome show
I had a great show but I know one of the
moment where they liked you more because
you the person I don't know about that I
don't know I don't know I I see Willie
destroy yeah but it was didn't like him
or the person but they like the other
guy who the person no no no no no no no
no no the story is we would go drink
after the show every time and then every
time it still does that it start again
it's writing yet too much and I would
always go that's and I would tell people
this is my cue
I'm out cuz you'd be turned into an
[ __ ] and that a I see he always
leaves you always mr. honey's right and
then I'll be like how to eat this [ __ ]
and then this one time I said I'm out
you know I'm out and I went walking to
the hotel and then I stopped I saw a bar
full of girls and I said you know what
I'm over there I'm gonna have a good
time and I was taking pictures and I was
sent it to him I go look what you missed
out on you know with the girl and then
and then I go you should like why are
you acting like this I couldn't even
open up my phone oh and then I go to the
hotel and I noticed like 2:30 in your
shirt or saying we're all more different
we were in the same room at night
[ __ ] in the same room that high
I don't know if you've ever no no and
he's no work at the other weekend that
we yes and the next you know I get to
the hotel and it's like it's open I go
what the [ __ ] and I go in and there's no
clothes his clothes are gone and my
t-shirt ripped in the toilet he knows
it's no secret I've told the stories I'm
50 with my wallet my charger did it off
with my shoes I had sandals he took off
with my bag so all I had were the
plastic bags you get in the hotel I a
ticket or even cash I had cash thanks to
the merch yeah I've cash in my pocket
things why do you take it well that's a
pussy-ass because it no it was in the
car he didn't know oh you know but he
was so drunk
yeah just drove [ __ ] that and then I
don't know how I asked him I haven't
said dude how did you get home like what
did you do how you stopped somewhere
how'd you get home bag we're a little I
what porn Garfield into the six-hour
drive did you not say maybe I should
turn around yeah maybe I should dude
what the [ __ ] around 8 minutes very
adamant man yeah and so but it was all
my fault it all turned into my fault and
I was like [ __ ] you man
we could have blame everybody for your
[ __ ] it showed it so then I get back
home and I say hey give my bags is he
sends his son with my stuff his son
drops and we were on the way there we
were doing it we he was telling me a
story about how his sons went to a party
and one of them left the other one there
and the other one got in a fight and
then the other one wasn't there to back
him up and he told him this whole story
you never leave a man behind
never Lee and so when his son came I
gotta wait til you dad about
story he told you you never leave a man
behind and then they looked at me like
[ __ ] yeah I don't know why he left
that's Robert did you did you mention
how you got home I missed that Greyhound
Greyhound where were these two people
nearly kill themselves yeah yeah this
was 2005 2004 on that time there's a
video and so that's it actually inspired
me to start this documentary about
making about starting comedy all the
[ __ ] we go through right that's awesome
and then that's one of the things that I
have and I and I invade like 50 random
I'm making one about ending comedy it's
my Instagram account I think wow that
one story huh that's one story but
that's not the the straw that broke the
camel's back I didn't work with it's not
I didn't work with him for months and he
kept begging me kept begging me come on
bro Wow and then we were gone the roadie
good we get along he was totally
respected me they were mentioned by
Gucci luckily but but the one that that
I said I don't want to work with you
anymore is when he he he heard negara
hijab de Guerra oh you were there no no
but I talked to I called him when it
happened and he didn't answer and then I
called Nick Guerra and I was talking to
Nick right after it happened right what
happened when taken yeah I'm sure you
just stay off [ __ ] Internet yes and
then I said what happened he told me
every what happened and then he said he
[ __ ] just went up Willy with others
wait wait no no Willy was Barr said I
was leaving corporate Christie will be
in Vegas yes yes it's dropping back he
made a [ __ ] 42-hour detour yeah Paso
to beat up another comedian yes yeah yes
I leave no stone unturned yes yes and
Nick Garrett
Nick garre's like Martin Rizzo he's like
more I know I like Nick I
Gera doesn't joke about looking like a
girl a funny man he doesn't joke about
getting his suit at build-a-bear ya know
why would I want to get in a fight with
a little guy like that and that was
where I stood maybe it was on the way he
was snarky dog so annoying good make you
turn two powers out of your way so I
didn't like that and I told them I wrote
a letter long I said do I don't want to
work with people like that
and that's bullying I go die we're still
friends today and if the movie comes up
yeah sure but I don't want to hit the
road in a hotel I don't hit the cost of
our efforts boy now a pony show shebar
go tells me stories like well there you
are brother that's what it is
thank you yeah yeah it's it's it's like
it's crazy but you know it would only
come out when he drank with me it only
came out just at night the guys every
night every first I would start back in
the day he'd like mr. Hyde and mr. Hyde
and in mr. Jekyll was in a while yeah
and then and then during the day boy
like all cool all cool you teach you how
to ride buy you breakfast sometimes I'm
broke yeah he put everything he'll tell
you 1 dollar bill and then later on
tonight he'll talk take it off you yeah
[Laughter]
one time brother who pay me $100 to
leave the room bro cuz I'm chief wanted
to come and I said alright so the cheek
left cheek red my toes broke ha before I
left
yeah you wanted some for the blackness
we're both under the blanket as you came
in and you know my toes were out and she
started like ok whichever of my toes
were laughing back
lovely broken prolly pops didn't faze
her his story to be about you slapping I
did where I don't know he just goes that
[ __ ] slap oh yeah you know the
romera bar sub need a butter he did
earlier about letting it go and then I
thought he made a joke instead of
elevator and over like three white dudes
in suits they were like ages and they
laughed real hard and what he said about
me and then I just slapped it in front
of ok I slapped on bro in front of those
three dudes and I looked at them and you
all wanna get [ __ ] slapped
okay keep [ __ ] laughing the
[ __ ] got off brother three dudes
got off so great that was mean you
[ __ ]
what do you do now huh you will get
stopped again [ __ ] you're too
intimidating what happened that he
didn't do anything like he says like a
ground and I just said it no he's did a
funny joke but he said I don't mind if
you make fun of me but if you're making
fun of a stranger's like I feel like you
should I impress them yeah and should I
praise you why [ __ ] you keep
laughing at girl few break at the
[ __ ] elevator we're getting off on
the fourth floor
yeah I will kill everything bro but
though I'd like to get embarrassed
yeah I don't bring Outsiders into some
Outsiders in common whatever you wanted
for the US but this was the outsider
laughs did I feel like okay yeah yeah
you trying to hurt me no right yeah yeah
well I went through a lot with my dad he
just called me that's why I just thick
skin through life and I choose your
battles move on you know yeah move on I
got the thick palm though that will do
that rule I won't tell me he'll bang on
me in front of his friend they know or
laugh and that's it and I did Rocco the
one right below my dad he'll jump me
later on bro when I got older to wait
for be wrong guys thank you need another
one I need a plug something road heads
podcast I just put out the first album
so today road heads yeah check it out
video yeah member 12th
laughs barks enter with flux if he
survived Oh and then uh
oh wait vlog yes I've driven a flock up
to five hospitals in one night and I
didn't know five existed in Alhambra and
right there they all put it rejected him
for that morphine shot so he went to
other one yes and it was the strangest
thing
wheeling yes it was a strange thing
because I would be like hey man this guy
needs help and they'd be like oh that
guy coming on his back yes yes it was
rough and I'd be like didn't want to pat
him cuz I thought I would hurt him more
and then he had a plastic bag yeah I
think at that point your brain starts
yeah fool you and thinking that you need
it I think it's the yeah and I mean it
wasn't it migraines yeah well he had
migraines but his condition is Marfan
syndrome but what happens is your
muscles your connective tissue seizes up
it starts to get hard so all of your
joints and everywhere there's connective
tissue and your skin it just gets hard
and is necessary for the more for the
migraines and stuff but it was causing
but I gotta say he's he's he's uh he's
moved up a lot in his physicalness I
mean the dude almost died he was in the
hospital bed and now he's walking around
with something yeah but dude I was just
totally impressed last time I saw him
he's so here's a flock oh hell yeah
we're so Flaco oh he's very upset too
and then I don't know if you saw Rudy's
last pose maretto
yeah fighting each other not the way
down
I'm all for Flaco fighting that battle
yeah oh no you're not good but Rudy
Moreno has mentioned I like we all gotta
you know yeah he brings up the whole
thing back gonna do something right to
be like exactly right all Godfather okay
nobody [ __ ] everybody never try to act
like Saints 20 years later Cosby right
oh it's long oh yeah it's long yes back
to an essay yeah you got it
hey thank you guys for having